A portion of this video is sponsored by last pass. The sauce, Kevin here,
and I'm being mugged by a baby. Why? Please? No, no,
I'm not giving you my wallet. Bloviating give me your wallet.
This is a mugging though.
It's not a buggy trying to make a math video and you are
baby child doll thing. You're not mugging me. Oh yes I am.
How much scratches in the wallet? If you are Jack, my name is Kevin,
not Jack and not a lot of money. Like 10 bucks. They'll go away.
Here's the deal. If I take your wallet today,
I'll find you tomorrow and give you $20.
That's a 100% return on being bugged by me.
Come on. There's there's no way that you'll possibly make good on that deal.
I can't trust you.
You you're just some creepy feeling baby doll,
your game, huh? 10 times then 10 times.
I'll give you a $100 tomorrow for stealing 10 bucks today.
Kind. No, no, no, no.
This is ridiculous. Where are you going to get a hundred dollars tomorrow? Ah,
no, I'm not giving you my wallet. I'm keeping 10 bucks, a thousand dollars.
What? $10,000 tomorrow. Five, 10 bucks right now, buddy,
by actually this is starting to get interesting.
Give me a second to think about this over here.
I need to start considering the odds of this actually happening.
What are the odds of a child jumping me on the street and then making good on
their promise to give me more money tomorrow. This is the only way I can decide.
I can compare the probability of it happening relative to the payoff. I'll get.
If it does, if the odds were 50% and I had $10,
I'd break even playing this game over time. If babies mugged me every day,
if the payoff is a hundred dollars, then I'd break. Even at 10% odds.
If the payoff is $10,000 and there's a better than a
0.1% chance,
which is one in 1000 that the baby delivers the 10,000 bucks to me
tomorrow. And it only costs me $10 today.
Then it's actually a smart move in terms of, of expected value.
$1 billion, Kevin,
1 billion by you give you $1 billion tomorrow for
stealing $10 in your wallet today, do the math,
do the math, right? All right, I'll do the math. All right.
So is there a one in 100 million chance that this scenario is
real? That's my break even point.
So if the odds are saying one in 50 million, this is a great deal.
Theoretically, if I'm wrong and it's one in 125 million,
then I've made a really bad decision here. I mean, think about it.
What are the odds that a super bored billionaire is sitting around with a few
other really bored billionaires.
And they're watching me as they play some kind of creepy social
experiment. They could give the baby doll the money tomorrow.
That sounds crazy and highly unlikely,
but is it possible? Yeah,
it's possible at a certain point.
The odds that this scenario is legit, make giving up my wallet,
worth it relative to the payoff.
It's just a wallet and I lose 10 bucks and I get a
mathematically plausible possibility of getting enough money to change tens
of thousands of lives, maybe more,
what would you do with $10 billion or a hundred billion
dollars?
I'd fill a swimming pool with peanut butter and then figure out the rest
from there.
The rewards here are very real on the expected value calculations.
Add up. So why would I not do this?
That's the rational decision.
It's like a lottery that's mathematically in my favor.
Here's a question.
Can I even figure out the real odds in a situation like this?
I'm not just flipping a coin.
I'm wondering what a weird inanimate doll thing is
going to do tomorrow. A hardcore mathematician,
fully committed to expected value would happily take this baby
muggers deal, but you're smarter than that. You know this isn't a good idea.
If you give this baby your wallet,
you're never seen either one ever again.
Baby needs to steal 10 bucks today,
but it's going to pay you a billion tomorrow. It makes no sense.
The baby knows the expected value calculation too,
and understands that it's perfectly rational for me to give up my wallet.
So why wouldn't she use that information to her advantage and pose a
scenario? She can see.
Exceed with 100% of the time. Again,
you're smarter than the math here, but can artificial.
Intelligence realize.
What you know, or would it just play the numbers?
Wait, what if it's not some weird lottery style payoff?
What if the scenario is not a good thing at all?
And instead is something terrifying.
What if the baby says they've got a biological weapon that will
harm millions and they'll unleash it unless you give them
your $10 does giving up your wallet as a
preventative measure,
make more sense than the scenario in which you were going to win a bunch of
money should be extremely low probability of something really
just converge to being zero.
At what point do we just consider such a small value meaningless?
And what if a very low probability event is offered
to a thousand people,
does it make sense for us to pass on it as individuals,
but to accept it, if we all do it together in a group,
that's really the impact of Pascal's mugging based on Pascal's wager
the centuries old philosophical argument about the existence of
God,
a scenario developed by Eliezer you'd Koski and further explored by Nick Bostrom
has tested the limits of belief in utilitarianism,
expected value. And decision-making in pretty weird scenarios.
If you want to dive further into the origins of Pascal's mugging,
you can read their explanations for free online and you should,
but all of this might matter to some not weird
scenarios like recycling,
a single soda can probably isn't going to save the environment,
but we have good reasons for thinking it'll lead to an important payoff.
Despite being irrational on the surface.
At a certain point,
we really can't comprehend how big something is or how good it
is or how dangerous it is.
So how can we possibly program artificial intelligence
to make the decisions that are actually in our best interest and
not just based on the best raw calculation.
So is this deal actually a good deal for
me?
Do I let the baby take my wallet for the possibility of tremendous
gain or to avoid a horrible disaster?
Even though I know it's obviously absurd.
So you gotta to give me a wine or not Jack now. No,
no, I I'm not. I,
I personally would rather do a little bit of good with my 10 bucks,
for sure. Then risk it for a near impossible monumental payoff.
But some of you watching this video would likely have a different answer and
that's okay. We both have perfectly valid conclusions.
And one of the many crucial things to consider as we advance
artificial intelligence is understanding those critically
important nuances of human intelligence
and saddle shoe wearing grifter doll
intelligences too, I guess.
And as always, thanks for watching real quick.
This portion of the video was sponsored by glass.
Pass it, frees your brain,
remembering passwords by auto-filling your usernames and passwords across all
devices and with their security dashboard,
which helps track and improve your password strength across the internet and
their new dark web monitoring to protect your accounts.
Your unlimited password storage is kept safe,
even have a secure password sharing feature.
So you never email someone your password. Again,
don't email someone your password,
and you can simplify online shopping for the holidays by having your payment and
shipping info filled out for you.
So to get 40% off last past premium, for a limited time,
go to lastpass.com/vsauce 40 or click the link below offer
expires December 8th.
Thanks to last pass for sponsoring this portion of the video. Okay, bye.
[Inaudible] give me your wallet.
This is I'm bugging $10,000 tomorrow
for 10 bucks right now, Jack, do the math, Kevin.